I want to talk about a really
interesting email that came in from a
viewer and it's so interesting in fact
that I want to devote a segment to it
today this is an email i received from
alan who wrote to me and said david do
you think straw Manning
oversimplification and extremism
is necessary in order to initiate
movement regarding an issue a lot of
people don't have the interest patience
time or intelligence to really dig deep
on an issue of course straw Manning can
be very unfair and obviously very
divisive but to some degree I think that
it can be an effective way to fight the
battle of ideas for example the
right-wing stance on guns is often seen
by the left as a result of rich
politicians and gun owners not caring
about the slaughter of children I
personally don't buy that but if I did
I'd be pissed off and yelling in the
streets too so basically what Alan is
asking me is whether the simple
unenhanced unembellished truth is enough
to inspire activism or whether you sort
of need to exaggerate the other side's
position to get people activating around
a political issue so let's take the
three one at a time right we have straw
Manning oversimplification and extremism
straw Manning straw Manning is
distorting someone else's position to
make it easier to refute or argue
against so you could strawman the
pro-gun views of people by saying they
don't care about dead children is that
literally true but probably not but if
you believe that their policy in support
of gun rights leads to dead children you
might tell yourself I'm okay straw
Manning their position because it's a
useful idea to get support another
example would be like imagine a
politician who's in favor of tax cuts
for the rich you could strawman their
position by saying they don't care about
destroying the economy when the truth is
they just don't believe tax cuts for the
rich are bad for the economy and it's
much easier to argue against the straw
man position I don't think straw Manning
is necessary to create political
activism I also don't think extremism is
necessary to create political activism
but I do want to talk about
simplification and oversimplification I
think that it is very useful maybe not
always necessary but oversimplification
often a good tool the truth is that life
is complex most people don't work in
politics most people they're busy living
their lives and earning a living and it
is often useful and not dishonest to
simplify an issue in order to get people
to see why it's important most issues
just aren't black and white but that
doesn't mean that it's a huge gray area
that's not closer to one side or the
other I believe it is not dishonest to
simplify issues for example abortion
being about controlling women the truth
is that it's more complex right there's
a debate about when life starts there's
a big religious component there's a lot
going on but the impact of the religious
rights position and the conservative
rights position on abortion is one where
women are not going to be allowed to
decide about their own bodies period so
I believe that it is useful to simplify
the issue in those terms
I believe it's useful in not dishonest
to simplify the issue of net neutrality
to freedom on the internet from
corporate power it's more complex its
regulatory its technical there's a lot
of stuff going on but in some
fundamental way that really is what it's
about it's about freedom from corporate
power on the Internet
climate change to give one more example
climate change is nuanced it requires
some understanding of science it can be
technical but it's not wrong to inspire
activism by saying we're wrecking the
only planet we have and every day we
don't fix it we're closer to our own
destruction that will catalyze activism
much more than talking about carbon data
from the last 800,000 years and I do
think that it's useful and not at all
dishonest some people may disagree with
me others may agree with the idea that
simplification is OK but not on the
issues that I think it's OK on but I'm
really really interested to hear from
people on this is it fundamentally
dishonest to simplify an issue not to
strawman not to take extremists
positions but to simplify and distill it
to its most important points I think the
answer is that it's ok but I want to
hear from people about this today's
episode of the show is made possible in
part by class
if you've ever wanted to sit in on
classes taught by world-class professors
at America's top universities without
actually having to attend those
universities in pay tuition class
central is the place to go it's a
comprehensive free search engine that
lets you find exactly the type of online
course you're looking for there are
courses from a ton of different
providers taught by some of the most
qualified professors in the country
thousands of courses to choose from many
of them totally free including courses
from Ivy League schools like Harvard
Yale Princeton other top schools like
Stanford and MIT you can search courses
by subject by University you can see
which courses are trending and you can
also rate and review courses and because
other users have already done this you
can see what other people have actually
said about the courses you're thinking
of taking I've been checking out a lot
of their courses on thinking both
critically and philosophically it's been
absolutely fascinating but they have
everything from political science to
philosophy economics math physics Comp
Sci business graphic design really
anything you can think of and you can
start taking classes taught by top tier
professors from the best universities in
the US right now by going to class
central.com slash Pakman that's class -
central slash PA que ma n I've also put
the link under this video if you're
watching on YouTube